[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
yesterday was day one of google i o 2013
their developer conference similar to
wwdc from apple and while there were a
ton of interesting announcements
yesterday i'm going to wait to summarize
the whole thing and give you maybe my
top impressions of it when the whole
thing is over so there are more events
today and more tomorrow so we're gonna
get to that whole summary later but
there was one particular announcement
yesterday that was extremely
mind-blowing that blew a lot of people's
minds including mine so without any
further ado we're gonna go ahead and
talk about it this is the google
experience galaxy s4 explained so
there's the original galaxy s4 it's a
very successful phone already in its own
right with more than six million sales
all across the country it's the
successor to the very popular galaxy s3
and it was announced a couple weeks ago
and it is doing extremely well
then another galaxy s4 was announced
yesterday which is why it was a little
bit mind-blowing but taking a step back
the day before the keynote or the day
before yesterday's keynote russell holly
gets all the props for this he posted an
article or basically published a rumor
but a basically confirmed rumor that
samsung would be releasing a galaxy s4
with stock android on it and that was a
basic summary of it and i just kind of
dismissed that as saying that seriously
like that's never going to happen there
is no incentive for samsung to do that
no incentive for google to do that why
would that ever happen doesn't make any
sense never going to happen no chance uh
and so we're watching the google i o
live keynote and sure enough hugo bear
is on stage and we've been talking for a
lot of different like a whole bunch of
different like things we've been
discussing apis and new refreshes to
cloud services and new announcements and
then for about five minutes he pulls out
a galaxy s4
and he starts talking about how the
galaxy s4 is a great phone and i'm
sitting there watching it's like this is
this really gonna happen like what is
this actually going to happen and then
he turns on the galaxy s4 and it's got
stock android on it it really does it
has stock android on it so at this point
my jaw is on the floor i have no idea
why he's doing this and he keeps going
and he's talking about how this is going
to be a nexus experience galaxy s4 not
only is he holding one and not only is
it a project that's come together in the
last week but this is going to be sold
in the google play store so this is the
google edition samsung galaxy s4 it is
going to be sold in the google play
store for 649
and it's going to be available on june
26th now about the specs of it this is
running pure android 4.2 jelly bean and
as you've heard the galaxy s4 running
touchwiz or the regular galaxy s4 has
had about eight gigabytes of storage out
of the total 16 that you usually get
because touchwiz takes up so much but
with stock pure android on the galaxy s4
you're gonna be able to have well a lot
more of that space back you're gonna be
able to claim more than about 10 gigs of
storage when you get this thing out the
box the updates for the software for
this google edition phone will be
managed straight from google that's the
thing so you're not getting updates from
samsung anymore you don't have to wait
for samsung or over the carrier for that
matter to add uh whatever software
features they want before pushing the
update as soon as there's a new version
of android you will get it on your
galaxy s4 that's what the google nexus
experience is and hugo was not even shy
about using the term nexus over and over
again in that presentation he called it
a nexus experience device which brings
up a lot of other questions that i'm
about to address but basically this is
another nexus now this is going to be
sold alongside the nexus 4 and the
google play store in about a month now
the galaxy s4 may not be as solid as the
htc one and by the way this is not
happening with the htc one as far as we
know as much as i wish it was but this
is not a solid built as the htc one and
it's not really as feature packed as a
regular galaxy s4 anymore and it's not
as cheap as the nexus 4 so it's really
in its own category in the google play
store it's not competing with anything
which leads us to the question
why why did this happen what does this
mean for the nexus line and what does
this mean for the galaxy line so for the
galaxy line this means
nothing pretty much absolutely nothing
now we do know that samsung and google
had to work on this a little bit at
least to get this going but as far as we
know samsung isn't going to be marketing
this at all they're going to market
their regular galaxy s4 and you're never
going to see ads for the nexus galaxy s4
for the nexus line on the other hand
this is a gigantic question mark but
there are two very clear paths that this
could take this initiative could take
one of two very distinct clear paths the
first path and what i think is very very
unlikely is the we're giving up on the
nexus path where the nexus 4 and the
galaxy nexus and that whole line of
devices is now over and we're going to
start to see basically a whole bunch of
these devices just start to get stock
androids so future htc devices future
samsung devices future flagships are
just going to get stock android and
become the next nexus so for all
intensive purposes if we go along that
path this is the next nexus now why i
think this is unlikely because google
doesn't use the nexus as a sort of a
sales point they don't use it for
anything much more than a halo device
and that's the problem is giving up that
halo device would be giving up a lot of
the direction that they were leading the
galaxy s4 has a physical home button it
does not have the on-screen buttons it
has a capacitive menu and back button
and it has a micro sd card slot in the
back which for all intents and purposes
makes it a super nexus but google for
the past two nexuses the galaxy nexus
they started to push on screen buttons
the nexus 4 they had even more same
on-screen buttons and they gave up
external storage moving from the galaxy
nexus to the nexus 4 so they're clearly
changing the direction and they really
want to see on-screen buttons in nexuses
why would they just give it up and stop
pushing that direction
that's that's very unlikely from what i
see anyway so that leaves the other path
the other path is to continue making
nexuses and we'll probably see a next
nexus phone later this year anyway but
they could also continue to make nexus
experience phones i mean imagine a play
store full of awesome devices running
stock android that would be pretty
awesome their device updates will all be
managed by google that would be pretty
sweet and uh they could just continually
add devices whenever they want and also
make actual nexus devices as they
continue to make those halo devices on
the side and they continue to do that
that's probably the more likely solution
i really don't see google giving up the
nexuses and just going straight to other
phones that other manufacturers make
because google worked really tightly
with samsung with lg and with htc to
make all of their nexuses so far they're
going to continue to do that as far as
we know so that's basically all we know
about the google edition samsung galaxy
s4 it's not a lot right now but it at
least answers the question what the hell
just happened uh obviously my jaw was on
the floor and again props to russell
holly i'll add all the links you guys
need to know right below the like button
to get all the information you need
about this google edition phone but
again hugo was not shy about saying that
this was a nexus experience device which
really raised a lot of eyebrows but uh
that is the google edition galaxy s4
either way that's been it thank you for
watching if you want to see my full
galaxy s4 review i will have that link
below as well and you can watch that and
decide if you actually want to pick this
up i don't know if anyone's going to be
buying this phone there's not really
much incentive to buy a 650 unlocked
phone it does have the same bands as the
current nexus 4 with att and t-mobile i
think it is and you also have lte
support but again for the most part most
people who have bought the galaxy s4
already aren't going to be all that
disappointed in it although some people
in the geek community are just going to
put signage and mod on theirs anyway
either way thanks for watching and i'll
talk to you guys in the next video
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
you